Australia's great Victoria Desert.
A featureless expanse of sand hills and
scrub the size of California.
Ed Kavanaugh is heading deep into this vast
wilderness drawn by something weird revealed
from space.
I've lived in Australia my whole life and
never seen anything quite like this before.
An image taken over the region on April 8th,
2021, has captured this pattern in the red
sands below.
Out in the middle of nowhere is this giant
carving on the earth.
It looks like kind of wedges of a pizza.
It's very strange.
The middle of it has been cleared in a way
that it forms almost a bull's eye.
The mystery symbol covers an area equivalent
to 600 football fields and has spokes up to
1400 feet in length.
The shape itself has been created with
precision, which can only mean that some sort
of government or military operation has
taken place here.
What's more, the remains of an identical
shape sit nearby.
Great effort appears to have been made to
erase evidence of it.
As a journalist, when I see something
clandestine in my own backyard, I feel
compelled to go and investigate it.
Officially, there are no towns near the site.
But evidence on the ground suggests
otherwise.
Wow. This is insane.
I mean, this completely deserted ghost town.
This can't just be a coincidence.
Just 15 miles from the mystery symbols sits
this ghost town.
Dozens of its buildings have been razed to
the ground.
This clearly would have been a very sizeable
community here.
It looks like it's been abandoned for
decades.
Whatever forced this town to flee.
It appears to have happened almost
overnight.
Oh, this is amazing.
All the chairs and equipment are left
exactly in place, as they would have been
decades ago.
Everyone's just got up and left.
In each room, Kavanaugh finds evidence of
government activity.
This vehicle was completely out of place
here.
It's clearly been modified for some purpose.
It's got a completely enclosed cabin to
separate this part of the vehicle from those
who are driving it.
The vehicle appears to be designed to contain
something extremely hazardous.
Satellite images of another ghost town in
Australia could offer a clue.
What we do know is that a town in Australia
did have to evacuate because of a toxic
asbestos mine.
Could this have been the same case in the
town we're looking at here?
Between the 1940s and the 1960s, miners in
the town of Wittenoom excavate around 165,000
tonnes of blue asbestos from the desert.
Over the years, 2000 people die from
unwittingly inhaling the cancerous fibres.
Before the government shuts down the mine
and wipes the town off the map.
It's actually the largest contaminated site
in the entire southern hemisphere.
That's big.
The nightmare scenario is that the ghost town
and the shapes in the image may be evidence
of another equally deadly disaster on
Australian soil.
One that authorities are trying to cover up.
Something bad has happened to you to make
people abandon this town.
And I'm certain it's got something to do
with those wagon wheel shapes I've seen in
the desert.
The indigenous people here call this area the
big evil.
And the journalist soon learns.
Why.
The closer I get to the wagon shapes, the
vegetation is getting thinner and thinner.
It's almost as if some sort of event is
taking place here that is just wiped all of
the life off the face of the earth.
Arriving at the coordinates, Kavner discovers
a vast flat area.
First thing I've noticed is these strange
hooks that are embedded into this concrete
slab. I'm not sure at all what these would
be pinning to the ground, but it certainly
adds to the mystery here.
Nearby, Kavner finds more objects not visible
in the satellite image.
Wow. Look at this. These look like some sort
of rocket launching devices.
They're incredibly old and brittle and all
rusted out.
The rocket launchers are weird enough, but
what really intrigues Kavner is what
surrounds them.
There's this field of green glass.
It almost looks like a green jade all across
the ground out here.
Millions of square feet of desert around the
mystery shapes shimmer with the deformed
beads of glass.
Kavner believes this is trinitite a
substance formed when sand is subjected to
temperatures in excess of 3000°F.
This suggests to me that this has to have
been made from a nuclear weapons test.
I must say I'm completely speechless
discovering this year.
What's concerning is that there are only nine
countries with known nuclear weapons
capabilities. And Australia isn't one of
them.
The idea is just unfathomable.
But there's just no other explanation.
And it's just completely shocking.
Hey, it's it's Edward Kavanaugh.
Kavanaugh turns to his newspaper contacts to
track down someone who might be able to shed
some light.
All right. Thanks.
Jeremy Lebois is a member of the Maralinga
Tjarutja, a council of local Aboriginal
peoples.
Hi Jeremy, How are you going?
Good, thanks.
He confirms that 60 years ago atomic testing
did take place in this desert, but not ones
conducted by the Australian Government.
Where we are today is where the British
tested seven atomic bombs.
They were bigger than what they dropped on
Japan.
In 1952, the British become the world's third
nuclear power and are desperate to play catch
up with the US and Soviet Union.
To do that, the small, densely populated
nation needs to persuade another country to
host their nuclear tests.
The British government looked for testing
sites in the US and Canada, but were turned
down.
And then Britain knocked on the door of
Australia.
Part of the old Empire.
And the Aussies go, You know what?
Yeah, we'll have your nukes.
Let's blow up some nukes in our deserts.
In exchange for sharing nuclear secrets.
The Australian Government grants the British
vast swaths of land for their tests.
But it's land that belongs to Lebois and his
people.
Jeremy How much notice were the traditional
owners of this land given about the nuclear
tests?
Absolutely nothing.
Not one of them ever, ever sat down with the
traditional owners and asked them for
permission. Not one of them.